[Music]
awesome okay welcome everyone to another
stream and a live lecture at the same
time
so today I'll be continuing the theme
from Tuesday analyzing my best wins in
the London system
we're going to continue with that team
because I think it's very good for Club
level players actually you will see that
it's possible to beat very strong
players like IMS and GMS and the last
one I did show my best game probably in
the London and my highest rated win so
in today's session we're actually going
to be seeing my games from the 2022
summer actually this summer in case
you're watching it in the future
um so a little back story
um we have two games from the
paleo open I played this summer and it
was like
a very nice chill tournament and
going to the beach before the game you
know like kind of chilling and hanging
out and enjoying my time there and to be
honest it was a tournament I did not
really want to prepare so much for the
openings although I was still spending a
lot of time preparing so when you
prepare you want to make sure you focus
a lot but again if you're playing with
the white pieces I was always going for
the the London system almost always not
all the time necessarily just to enjoy
the atmosphere a bit more and
repair a bit less so let's dive into it
this was around I think round number
five of the tournament and I started
with the usual D4 and then Knight F3 I
could have also started with the bishop
F4 move but I did not want to clearly
put my intentions on the board yet in
case my opponent wants to go G6 I might
do something else maybe force them into
playing uh
stuff with C4 or maybe actually continue
playing the London so I did not want to
reveal my hand and in the games we're
gonna see today neither of my opponents
played anything with G6 so maybe in the
future lectures I can show games I faced
them of G6 on move 2 maybe here or there
but today we're not gonna see any of the
G6 responses so I played Knight F3 my
opponent played E6 and you all guessed
it it's Bishop F4 so
as we saw last time
um this is maybe a bit harmless but it
can also be super harmful to your
opponents if they don't know how they're
facing my opponent responded with C5 and
also I did not really know how my
opponent was going to put his pieces so
that kind of gave me a bit more
comfortable time I would say because I
just had no idea what my opponent was
going to play so I did not get to
prepare much although I was debating
between playing many different openings
I ended up playing the London because I
couldn't decide on anything after
spending hours and hours
so we got into the main position of the
London just like in the last lecture and
in the last game I showed my opponent
played like this
and you can probably refer to that
somewhere
but in this case my opponent played the
move Bishop D6 tackling this bishop and
of course their idea is they want us to
take the bishop and then they will
recapture with the queen and play E5 and
they're gonna get a super comfortable
game here and I don't want that so
that's why I played the move Bishop G3
the point is that if black captures on
G3 I'm going to capture with the H Pawn
and then open up the H file and this is
good for me because it helps my Rook
kind of be involved with the attack
so what my opponent did he played the
move Queen to E7 he's actually trying to
prepare the move E5
and okay so how do we react against our
opponent trying to prepare something
first of all
the immediate question we have to ask
ourselves is what do they want to do
okay we established that they really
want to go E5 but how do we deal with
that how do I stop the move E5 and
actually I have two different moves I
can play in this position I can play the
bishop to B5
pinning this Knight
and I can also play what I did I played
the move Knight E5
because what what this is doing is that
if you take with the Knight this would
be a very bad blender because I have to
D take C5 that's a fork and my opponent
will lose a piece and if you take with
the bishop
then I'm not going to recapture
and then the game is going to go on and
there is quite some more Theory maybe
after Knight D7 but that is
uh maybe a different story quick
question in the chat says why doesn't
black push C4 at what moment
at this moment oops I'm sorry at this
moment do you mean C4 or earlier like
here
so at which moment
um are you recommending C4
anytime so why do they never play C4
well what the reason why they don't want
to play C4 now
is that they don't want to decide they
don't want to let go of the pressure on
the center so what this Pawn on C5 is
doing right is it's putting pressure on
on the D4 Square trying to get rid of
The annotation but I couldn't so this
point on T5 is putting pressure on D4
but if you play something like C4 right
now you no longer put pressure there I
can actually undermine you with this
move B3 get rid of your pressure and
after you take I take and now I can even
expand with C4 I can go Bishop D3 I can
continue my play however I want and
unfortunately in this case you cannot
play B5 because your knight on C6 is
hanging so you cannot really back your
opponent on C4 and you don't want to do
that if you did the same thing here for
example while you're while you could
technically back it up with B5 I can
still play B3 and after B5 I can further
attack this Pawn with A4 and if you play
something like A6 well your Rook is not
guarded so I can always take and you can
never recapture because your Rook is
hanging so C4 is not really something
the black player wants to do unless the
bishop is on D3 and there's a much
better timing to it so for example a
line where people play C4 I have seen
and also faced myself is the move Bishop
E7 let's see why it goes something like
H3 let's say black castles or maybe
another move Bishop D3 and this idea of
C4 exists in this situation where black
can get a Tempo on this bishop and then
try to launch a queen side attack what
this would allow white to do though is
play something like Queen E2 not not
necessarily Queenie too but Something
Like Queenie 2 followed by E4 breaking
the center and trying to launch a king
side attack because the most common idea
we have is
if the center is closed right this is
closed Center there is no pressure you
should definitely try to attack on the
flanks exactly what black is doing we're
gonna do the opposite on the other side
because we have more pieces on the king
side that can cause trouble especially
this bishop on C2 so my opponent played
Bishop D6 and then we got to this
position 97 95 and here instead of
taking he played the move Knight E7 and
I was definitely within my preparation
but I just could not remember everything
because I I didn't expect this line and
I didn't check it so I was trying very
hard to remember what's actually the
preparation was because my opponent's
idea is very simple if I take on D7
they're gonna recapture and I can almost
always I mean I can actually never stop
this move E5 if I play F4 now I shut
down my bishop and I'm not a big fan of
this it's not going to be good for me
and I don't really want to play F4 just
yet
because
I'm not really sure how the play
develops after let's say my opponent
castles and then he has this idea of
playing F6 at some point kicking this
Knight out of the way and then trying to
go E5
so this is a potential
danger I was kind of like scared of also
what kind of comes to my mind now is
maybe they can play the move F6 here
because yeah usually F6 would have been
a blunder but in this case after check
maybe there is the move G6 and I'm not
saying this is necessarily true but
after Knight takes G6 which is the
common idea to win The Rook after takes
we would win The Rook but I'm not sure
what happens if they play something like
uh Queen F7
putting some extra pressure on this
Knight
maybe this is not exactly true because
maybe there is this move F5 this does
require calculating but I think the
Knight escapes from here so it doesn't
quite work but
it's risky so maybe F6 is not good maybe
they're just gonna castle and then play
F6 but that's something to keep in mind
there's a lot of pieces hanging in the
position which I don't want to get
involved with so what I did was I played
them of Bishop B5 I could kind of
remember something like this
um from when I whenever I Was preparing
not specifically for this game in
general with the idea that you cannot
Double Take on E5 at any moment with
regardless of what piece you capture
with you cannot take on E5 back because
I'm gonna take and whatever Knight you
have left on D7 or C6 is pinned so you
cannot capture on E5 and this in fact
happened in the game and here my
opponent played Bishop back to C7
so their idea is that I'm gonna Castle
next move I'm going to put pressure here
if you're gonna go F4 well you better
play it now or maybe the next move
because otherwise you're going to lose
your Pawn or you have to give up your
Bishop pair or I'm gonna break with F6
at the convenient time and get the
center you're not going to be happy
overall with your play and whenever
white goes F4 by the way black does
sometimes have this idea of playing C4
in this case
oops hopefully I didn't do anything
wrong with the mic and then
Queen C5
so
um
F4 was not in my agenda but what can I
play here then if I'm not gonna go F4
if I'm not gonna do anything like that
how do I protect my
um Pawn let's say
on E5 how do I take care of it
see if anyone in the chat
has any suggestions
or in person of course
E4 is a suggestion
E4 is interesting but I don't see I
don't see how you're defending this Pawn
if I castle for example
I don't see how you are really taking
care of anything because if you take
take now you're exposing your king even
further right
we don't want to do that Knight F3 is a
good suggestion yeah everybody's saying
Knight F3 but let's say I Castle how do
we play then we Castle he castles right
okay
so maybe he's gonna go like Bishop D7 I
don't know and I don't see I don't
exactly know how do we like continue to
play yeah sure I can attack his Queen
but his Queen is not going to be lost
he's gonna go Queenie age he has some
defense against it and okay I wasn't
very happy with this like I don't know
how to attack I don't know how to
proceed in this position F6 is probably
going to come at some point
and yeah maybe maybe we're not doing
that fantastic we need something more
Dynamic and whenever I played the London
I don't just play the London for the
sake of playing London right I I would
like to attack somehow I played the move
Queen G4 and what's the idea of Queen G4
well our our opponent with their last
move actually we always should ask
ourselves what our opponents want with
their last move even if it's like a
retreating move
our opponent always has a purpose on the
next move always even if they recapture
something even if they are doing in like
a empty looking move they do want to do
something and my opponent wants to
Castle it's his own right it's the
simplest and simplest thing he can ask
for but I don't want him to castle with
such ease so the reason I play Queen G4
is if you Castle now
which I think is okay I mean it's not
like losing or anything but in this case
this runs into some serious Danger
let's see if the the chat can figure out
kind of how it might lead to some
dangerous position
for
um for black
take the Knight then Bishop H4 Bishop F6
yep
exactly takes takes and then Bishop H4
threatening the queen and this actually
forces you to play F6 in my opinion
because if you play like Queen somewhere
back I'm gonna play the worst one
probably which is Queen E8 now I go
Bishop to F6 I'm threatening mate you
have to respond you have to go G6 and
now I bring my queen from H4 or from G5
actually probably better from G5 to H6
to G7 and you cannot stop it because
even if you try
well I'm fine you can take it and after
takes takes you cannot stop the mate
so that's the point
that's my point I played Queen to G4
with the idea that if my opponent
castles which is very natural I'm gonna
take on C6 and then go Bishop H4 okay
sure he could have maybe played F6 and
then sacrificed a pawn and then the game
goes on it's not the end of the world I
would say but it's not ideal to give up
a pawn right you don't want to just give
up a pawn and play the game nobody wants
to to do that
um they're not gonna get in huge trouble
but they're just going to be down upon
for
some compensation but maybe not full
compensation so what my opponent did
actually is he played the move Queen f8
which slightly surprised me I would say
although I think I understand his idea
behind it his idea is as far as I
understood during the game is to go
Bishop D7 and Castle long so they're
like I'm gonna cover the king side with
my queen and I'm gonna run to the other
side
and I'm like okay that actually makes
sense you know he wants to
um
he wants to go to the other side oh Brad
in the chat asks why take first I'm
assuming you're you're saying why take
here first and why not Bishop H4 yeah so
Bishop H4 immediately is also possible
probably very good move but a slight
concern is if they oh actually you're
right Knight E5 I calculated this now I
recall everything now it takes E5 as
possible but here
you take on E7 and after Knight G4 if
you take the Rook I would say black has
decent compensation
but I remember recalculating here I was
going to go Bishop C5 so you are right
I'm not forced to take the Knight first
because Bishop C5 says that I'm still
attacking your rook and if you go Rook
d8 to rescue it I'm gonna go back to E7
and I'm gonna trap The Rook so
you're absolutely right I do not have to
take on C6 it's definitely an option but
if I want to preserve the bishop pair
and
this would be the right move probably
better than Bishop takes Knight so
that's a good catch
um
Queen f8 yeah Queen f8 to me it looked
it looked a bit
passive I would say so how do we try to
take advantage of that well what do we
have to do
like what do you do in this situation
with the with the white pieces
what would you guys like to play
you take the Knight absolutely
absolutely it's time to uh
the queen has Castle yes it is time to
ruin the pawn structure because if my
opponent wants to go Bishop out castles
long I want the pawn structure ruined so
that I can attack someday uh if they're
on the queen side maybe I can swing my
queen suddenly to A4 and put pressure to
all these squares with just a very
simple shift and now what do we do very
simple we Castle why Castle because just
finish your development it's quite
simple instead of instead of going maybe
crazy with like F4 F5 or whatever I just
want to first develop my pieces and ask
my opponent what do you actually want to
do in this position
and my opponent replied with Bishop A6
attacking my Rook so how do we respond
what do I have to do in this situation
my Rook is being under attack and I have
plenty of options here I can play rookie
one I can play Rook D1 they're all super
tempting like I mean how do you even
identify the difference between Rook E1
and Rook D1 why should The Rook be on E1
why should The Rook be on D1 or should
it be on C1 or should it be on B1 to be
honest I think all of those moves have a
purpose you can put it on E1 to go E4
you can go to D1 because it's a
semi-open file and it might actually
open you can go to C1 because you can go
C4 you can even go to B1 I'm not gonna
blame you for anything because you might
want to go b4a4 and The Rook is going to
be super helpful so all of those moves
and there's also C4 also as an option
mentioned in the chat C4 is also a move
so there are so many moves in this
position and it was super hard to decide
and what did I do very practical Choice
by the way I could have easily spent
quite a lot of time like 15-20 minutes
thinking about this position where the
Rook belongs I just played the move
rookie one am I saying that it's the
best Maybe not maybe yes but it's just
very practical I just played it because
I naturally felt like The Rook just
should go to E1 and the queen should
have an escape Square on D1 just in case
it gets in trouble
and yeah that was my thought process
Queen A4 was definitely something I was
looking at because it double attacks the
bishop and the pawn and if my opponent
takes the Bish The Rook
then I take on C6 and then I'm gonna
either win The Rook or win the bishop
and then the other Bishop but the
problem with that is what we call this
intermediate move concept where my
opponent can play the move Bishop B5
attack my queen force my queen to leave
the pressure from C6 say I go back to C2
and then they take my rook and now I'm
not gonna be happy because I just lost
an exchange for nothing
so
we don't want to get that tactic but
what I did was
I played the movie rookie one again I'm
not claiming this is the best move but
in my opinion I wanted to go E4 at some
point and then take and then maybe C4 at
some point maybe take again if I get the
opportunity and then go E6 if I can and
then this King and Rook they're aligned
yes for now it's very imaginary that
this pawn move going forward will lead
to something but I did feel that this
was the right move was C4 a possibility
for sure
I just didn't want my queen to be like
defending this guy and have to deal with
something like H5
actually very critical situation for my
Bishop on G3 if I do something wrong my
Bishop can easily get trapped
on G3 so I have to watch out for this
King side attack as well
so
I played rookie one my opponent played
the move H5 hitting my queen I did play
Queen A4 attacking both the bishop
and the pawn he did Play Bishop B5 and I
brought my queen back to C2 so why did I
go from here to there and not all the
way back immediately what was my purpose
of making my opponent gain a Tempo with
Bishop B5 while retreating well multiple
things I would say that the bishop on B5
is more subject
to attacks like C4 A4 and it's kind of
hanging out in the middle of the board
um for no obvious reasons so
and yeah once my once the pieces kind of
go forward I'm gonna kick this guy out
take this guy open up the position try
to try to attack and it also keeps the
Rooks connected so one day I might play
the move like Rook a to D1 and that was
another reason why I picked the E1
Square for the F Rook because maybe this
Rook on A1 will join the attack from the
D file that's what I was thinking
so my opponent played H4 attacking my
Bishop of course I'm not gonna give up
my bishop and my opponent here played
the most surprising move I would say of
the game he played Bishop from C7 to A5
took me a while to understand
um what the
idea of this move is I mean
I I understand what it is his point is
that he asked himself the question what
does white want to play White definitely
wants to play C4 so he played the move
Bishop A5 anticipating C4 and if I go C4
he's going to take on
um D2 and after Queen takes he's just
going to capture the pawn so I think
that's his idea
but is C4 my only chance
I don't think so I think I have other
ideas too so
I played A4 hit the bishop Bishop
dropped back and now I think I have
multiple different choices and
a couple of them are good what I did is
definitely decent as well so
I'm curious how the chat would play in
this position
um that was definitely calculating quite
some stuff here but
I think there are a couple of good ways
you can proceed with the white pieces
here so let's see B4 is one suggestion
okay
everybody's saying B4
the chat has been hanging out with me a
little too much
E4 is another move but yeah you guys you
guys you guys can guess my moves now I
played B4 because yeah everyone is
saying before I'm actually like
shocked okay a couple people are not
saying before but everyone is spamming
before so yeah that's what I played
because well simply because if you take
I take right and then I'm attacking C6
while I'm attacking the bishop so that
means you cannot win my Pawn
um although like you can still maybe try
to do this but it doesn't work because I
take there I take yeah and if you take I
give a check and then I take the Rook or
you have to block with the bishop I win
the bishop so
yeah perfect chat is on fire so they he
played Bishop C7 now what
I mean my opponent is a strong
International master
um or he's a Fida master I'm not sure
but he's super strong so he's not going
to fall for that
what do we do now he I mean yeah we
tried the Cheap Trick did not quite work
um so how do we proceed in this moment
instead of Bishop A4 what about
Rook G5
okay I see there's a quick question
let's answer that it's typed upside down
but I understand the idea so the
suggestion is instead of playing Bishop
to A5
what would have happened if your
opponent played them of Rook H5 with the
idea to go G5 and then trap this guy
very good question actually and it's
also attacking this guy at the same time
um
as far as I remember
I can even play the move E4 here
it might not be the most accurate but I
can definitely play it
um
and another thing is I can definitely
play Knight F3 I think that's what I had
in mind worst case and then go E4 next
move
but you can also think about playing
C4 here it's another idea and after
takes maybe then play something else
like maybe 94 or something give up give
up some material but get some initiative
and so on so something to think about
I'm not a hundred percent sure how it's
possible to react but it's possible
definitely something like this or maybe
A4 first and then something else but
good question this is a good move I
would say also in the worst case worst
case although I don't really want to do
that probably E4 is the move E4 Bishop
takes
Bishop takes Rook takes
maybe something like
oh actually I know we take you cannot
take with the Rook because I go C4
and if you take I take you take
and maybe C4 here kind of open up the
position like I'm just playing with
instincts Without Really calculating
anything you just kind of go uh go
forward and if after E4 G5 I would say
we sacked this Pawn we go back and if
you ever take I take and you're gonna be
in some deep trouble in this file you
cannot probably just casually play
whatever because it's just gonna be
super dangerous and if you take I'm
gonna go C4 Open up The King The King
The Rook they're just not coordinated so
even though I'm down upon I'm fine with
it like Pawn is not that important if I
can get to your king so
um Knight F6 would Fork the pawn and the
Rock at what moment
at what moment I feel like it was in in
some different line but yeah it was
probably in the line where I said Knight
goes to E4 something like this try to go
there
maybe but there's this guy right
so it doesn't quite work but anyways
fast forward to the game
E4 he played Queen E7 I played E4 here
by the way so Knight B3 is definitely
interesting too I thought that was
recommended in the chat definitely a
move to try to go to C5
um but I played E4 because I want to try
to use my Rook
on
um
on E1 the whole point of me playing
rookie one was to actually go E4
I could also maybe play something like
C4 so there are plenty of options but I
wanted to at least semi-open this file
if I can open up something with this
real gun you want I might benefit from
it quite a lot and my opponent logically
he's like okay I actually want to go
short castles you know what I changed my
plan I'm gonna go there
and then I'm not gonna go this way I'm
like okay that makes sense so how do I
deal with that my opponent's about to
run to the king side and I don't really
have any attackers on the king side left
like there is nobody left everyone is in
the queen side hanging out or the center
so if I were to cut the board into like
three sections I have my queen and the
Rook on the queen side I have a bunch of
guys two guys on the center and then I
have the bishop that's it on the king
side so I don't really have any
attackers
so what do I do how can I try to prevent
him from running away from me
in this position
Knight F3 maybe to go Bishop G5
interesting
Knight F3 castles Bishop G5 yeah
definitely a possibility
definitely a possibility and then try to
go after this guy is he gonna Castle
immediately after Knight F3 maybe maybe
not this is a good move I would say
so here you want to just gang up on this
guy and then continue the game so Knight
F3 is a good move that's not what I
played but I think it's a good move
ed5 cd5 and then Rook E3 is a suggestion
something like this with the idea to
kind of prepare bring another piece and
then go Knight F3 Bishop G5 I like that
too that's another very good suggestion
these are all very good ideas by the way
I had something completely different in
my mind and it was more of a positional
approach I would say not super concrete
towards where his King was going but it
was
it was more like
I'll let you Castle
but I'll win material if you do that
that was the kind of approach I took and
in this position I played Bishop E3 so I
played E4 and then I made some space for
my Bishop to sort of come back and take
on C5 and if you were to Castle of
course that's the whole point right I'm
gonna take on C5 and then take your Rook
up in exchange
probably I'm gonna win the game
so my opponent he took on E5 Free Pawn
because I under defended my Pawn he's
like
I'll take it why not if you're giving me
a free Pawn I'll take it okay now I
think the move is quite interesting so
for sure I can take on C5 it's
definitely a good move
but I was like hmm
maybe I can maybe I can do a bit more
because his Bishop on E5 is kind of like
loose so and I don't really like my
knight on D2 I'm like I can actually
improve it I played Knight F3
I attacked the bishop on E5
if you retreats to C7 which he didn't
now I'm gonna take so now I just
suddenly improved my knight with the
tempo and then maybe next move I'm gonna
take on D5 start opening things up and
also maybe I'm gonna use my Rook on D1
so let's say you play the Queen to D7 or
something right now I can potentially
take one day I'm not forced to I can
bring my Rook try to go B5 and this king
is suddenly not finding any shelter
so
my opponent after Knight F3 played
Bishop D6 he's like okay I'm not gonna
immediately allow that but then I played
them of E5 I'm like okay you gotta go
you cannot stay on D6
and then he played Bishop C7 and then I
took the reason I did all this is I have
full control of the dark squares and
actually the most ideal scenario for me
would be to trade these guys off and
then my knight would dominate as Bishop
because the bishop on A6 is super
useless doesn't do anything it's not
contributing to anything it's not
attacking anywhere it's just not useful
so that's my dream scenario I would like
to get rid of that Bishop in any case
and then pure domination on the dark
squares so my opponent played Queen D7
and by the way there are many other like
good moves I see in the chat like some
some of the viewers they suggested F4
all of this is good but I don't really
want to like launch my pawns and maybe
weaken my king I know this is super
hypothetical but like this F4 Pawn is
like loose so I want to just slowly
improve my pieces not like pushing too
many pawns more like pieces not the
pawns you know that made more sense to
me my opponent plays Queen D7 so okay
what does he want to do well maybe he
wants to Castle long but A7 is hanging
so he's not gonna give up A7
and I'm like this bishop
is doing great this Knight is doing well
I would say I mean I can put it on D4
but why the Rook on E1 is like doing
fantastic I mean I don't really have a
better Square for any of those guys but
I was like the queen
I mean am I really maximizing the queen
I told myself no I don't think so
and here I played the move Queen to D2
what's the point well Queen to D2 I want
to go to G5 I want to take on G7 I'm
very aggressive now at this point I'm
like okay I can uh I can try to go get
him
A5 to prevent Bishop B6 is another
suggestion well I don't really mind
Bishop B6 to be honest if Bishop B6 I
put my Bishop on D6 if you go back I
honestly don't mind the trade that much
because
the dark squares are gonna be my control
so he's not gonna do that
Queen D2 Rook H5 and okay I think here
um
I think here I played
a very good move
and this is probably what separates like
a GM's from like maybe other players I
would say so let's see who can guess the
move in the chat
I would say this is a this is a move
I would play almost always I don't know
maybe I'm not sure
like if I see this move I'll play it
nine times out of ten
we have more space shouldn't we stop a
trade yes but this trade I like I like
the trade of the dark squared Bishops in
a specific situation
I'm not gonna trade all the time I'm not
saying trade all your pieces
um
and yeah okay one suggestion is and the
sentence exactly is I'm too fearful and
played H3 okay that's interesting
because that's exactly what I played H3
and I think this is a great move by the
way and many many players are saying H3
many of the viewers why H3 it's I mean
aren't we trying to Checkmate the guy I
thought we were just doing something
with his King why are we playing H3 well
H3 is uh first of all I don't want to
get back cranked at any moment I also
don't want my opponent play H3 and get
counter played any at any instance I'm
just gonna play H3 myself
so okay he has zero counter play now
and that's the whole point I don't want
my opponent having any counter play
whatsoever he plays this move Bishop to
C4
okay Bishop to goes to C4 great I don't
really care I played Queen to D4 what do
I want maybe I want to take the pawn
I might be too greedy well my opponent's
like okay no I'm not giving you the one
okay and I'm like okay your Bishop on C4
is annoying
I'll kick you out Knight D2 Bishop went
back to Asics and we have been playing a
lot with those pieces which piece did we
ignore the Rook well it's the time okay
do you want what's my idea what's my
threat with rookie D1 well rookie D1 not
only improves The Rook on A1 but it
actually threatens something sneaky it
threatens the move Knight E4
so it'll say you played some random move
like G6 I'm gonna go Knight E4 and I
want to go put my knight on D6 so this
useless Knight on D2 wants to land on D6
and is my opponent gonna allow that
no he's not he had almost no time he was
playing like
um on increment it's almost like mate
but
it's just not coming through for example
I was even calculating the idea for here
and after you take you go Queen E4
you're trying you're threatening
Checkmate you're so close
he has the small Rook h8
he just goes back in the fence
I mean it looks like he has Bishop D3
too I had all this kind of calculated I
can actually take on e4 and I would be
fine because you cannot recapture it
because it's made however there is this
rookie shade defense that holds
everything together and if I give him
the next move he might go Queen C7 try
to trade this queen
not gonna work so I cannot go Knight E4
what I did I played this move C4 all of
you guys were thinking about this move
C4 C4 C4 well what do I want to do kind
of want to expand on the queen side of
it maybe not take I mean my opponent
doesn't have much time so he's like
30 seconds almost about the flag trying
to not flag he took on C4 he's like
there is no immediate danger because if
I play something like this he always has
the small rookie chick he's kind of
relying on this defense
so
and I'm like okay I'll actually take it
and I'll go Queen D6 I took that pawn so
the position opened up a little bit more
and his King is way more exposed than it
was before because now his D5 Pawn left
I if I was him I would try to stay as
solid as possible and not lose
immediately but
it's kind of hard to just stay passive
and not do anything the whole game he
wasn't doing much right if you look at
it this Rook hasn't moved at all this
stroke moved once but it's like you
don't really want Rook H5 maybe bishop
B6 definitely it's possible Bishop B6
could have been a could have been an
attempt to kind of like
get out of things but I don't see how
you get out of anything if I'm like okay
just show me what you have are you gonna
really take this and then stay like that
without doing much
it's just too passive you know like you
can go
play Queen D7 maybe or something like
that but then the Rook is Gonna Come
This is hanging
it's just not happening you know Bishop
E7 it still is not going to solve your
problems right I'm gonna take take maybe
give a check
and then Rook D6
this is chaos
I mean I'm gonna take go rookie seven
mate is coming it's impossible it's
definitely not fun so my opponent played
Queen B7 he's trying to do something I'm
not sure even what but I played here
there now all I have to do is gather my
pieces and end the game somehow I need
these guys in the game The Rook on E1
did his job
it did its job and now it's time to
bring this room what is the idea of Rook
D6 well since my opponent doesn't have
much time I'm trying to kind of provoke
him to play something like Bishop E7
this would end the game immediately to a
nice finish with the Rook takes D6 and
after F takes I can go Queen G6 pick
this guy up
that's it it's just game over
so what he did was he played Rook out
five
and
I played them of Rook e to D1 sort of
trying to maybe play like
Rook D7 or something and of course it
wasn't
um
super obvious what I wanted but I did
kind of want my opponent to take on E5
which he did and in this position I
played Queen F4 attacking the rook and
trying to invade from H6 to f8 so a nice
line for example could have been Rook F5
Queen f8 Rook H5 but then I have Rook
takes d8 and Rook takes d8 Queen f8 mate
so what happened instead in the game is
my opponent played the move Rook H5
trying to cover the H6 Square
but he forgot that I can go Rook takes
E6 and he resigned here because after it
takes that would have been made
so that was the that was round number
five
and uh that was a good game so
hopefully that was something educational
but now on to the next game
now on to the next game this is actually
round number seven of the same
tournament
so Mac story again I'm hanging out at
the beach before the game don't know
what to do what opening to play and then
the light bulb comes to my mind play the
London but then I tell myself okay I
just played the London like two games
ago and now I'm playing a grand master
and the grand Masters definitely gonna
prepare I mean I just played London like
two games ago like impossible and then I
go D4 Knight F6 Knight F3 the same way
he goes E6 Bishop F4 and then my
opponent starts thinking and I'm like
what
you did not prepare anything I just
played the London like all and I've been
playing the London like somewhat
regularly at this point
my opponent started thinking he was like
thinking hard he's like which system do
I pick
and then he goes D5 now all of you know
this E3 Bishop D6 okay and I'm like I'll
deviate a bit I'm not gonna put the
bishop on G3 just yet just be a bit
cheeky castles Knight D2 C5 and I'm like
okay it's time let's go to let's go to
um
G3
he played
um
Queen C7 and the idea of Queen C7 is
that black wants to go Knight bd7 and
then go
E5 that's their idea and I know that so
I took on C5
and my opponent captured with the queen
and I played Bishop D3
so I have played this position multiple
times before
and my opponent responded with Knight
bd7 and here this is I would say a
critical moment if you do not know the
position so this is not your usual
London system position this is a bit
more different than that so what do we
do with the white pieces we don't have
our Pawn on D4 anymore it's it's no
longer there we took on C5 it
disappeared now so what do we do
how do we play options we have we have
options yes
we do have options
what is our option
what would you play if you were playing
with the white pieces I think there are
there's two good moves here
as far as I know yeah
night move night mode where Castle
um
castles Maybe
but I don't really want a castle because
then we kind of gave up the center for
nothing right I would try to trade
everything and offer a draw
I don't want to do that like see I'm
almost 100 points higher rated than my
opponent and I want to win the
tournament I don't just want to make
draw and not win the tournament so
that's not what I went for
it's a smart choice maybe sometimes but
not always I played the move Queenie too
it's the idea of Queenie 2 well I want
to go E4
and then go E5
if I can do that I'll be I'll be very
happy
so
that's what I played my opponent took on
G3
I captured and I was like okay thank you
because that's very nice I am putting
more pressure on H7 and of course if I
cancel my pressure will disappear but
um my opponent's not gonna
I mean I hope he wasn't expecting me to
Castle short because there's no way he
played H6 okay so we have developed
everything but our King is still in the
middle what do we have to do king safety
where do I put the king here or there
at this point
I think everybody knows that's 100 times
out of 100 times our Castle king queen
side because I am not about castling
short and playing this game slowly I
want to Checkmate this guy
um as fast as I can
so my opponent played Rook E8 what is he
preparing well my opponent is probably
preparing something like E5 and E4
it's pretty cool but
I launch
E4 before him
and then what he does is he takes I take
he takes and critical moment of the game
do I take what the queen or do I take
with the bishop
what do we do
Queen takes is the most natural
right
Queen takes is the most natural
threatening Queen H7 what was my
opponent gonna do is he gonna let me of
course not he's gonna play Knight to F6
and once my queen goes somewhere also
this is under attack right I have to
keep that in mind so
choices I can I can try to trade the
queen Maybe
play an end game do I really want to
play in end game no not really
I can play this
then my opponent gets the bishop out the
bishop might go to C6 The Rook might
come and if I don't mate him soon
it's not going to happen I can also go
Queen H4
but then I have to deal with E5 E4
coming
Bishop G4 coming
Rook joining the defense would like not
B8 Rook C8 Rook d8
I don't want any of that
so I played Bishop takes
and this was this was quite sneaky I
would say I really had this one trap
that my opponent might fall for
and he fell for it and he played I guess
I'll ask you guys what what did Black
play what is my trap let's see if you
can predict
everyone is going to look for something
tactical now it is kind of Tactical yeah
my opponent played
um
the most obvious move
and the most obvious move is a bad move
Knight F6 okay so there is a chat
there's a question they're asking why do
we not go Queen C2 and we play Queen E2
I'm gonna address that actually that's a
good question so they're saying why did
we not play Queen C2 and played Queen E2
well I'll answer it very simple terms I
put the queen so that after all these
exchanges happen although it didn't
happen in the game I have my queen in
front of my Bishop so that I can check
Maiden with my queen that's the idea
right I'm also supporting
the E4 E5 push
I'm supporting the fork you know if I
have my queen on C2 I'm not supporting
anything
right okay in this case I don't need it
because it's not attacked by sufficient
number of like it's not defended by
enough pieces but say his Queen drops
back to C7 I want my queen supporting my
push and Queen on C2 is not as dangerous
it's not threatening anything right it's
just I would say it's just a it's just
blank there is no there is no threat and
maybe he'll just rush with something
like this I have to sort of defend and
then he might take take
and then maybe take take and then Knight
F6 and then he can run with E4 maybe
something like this it's just annoying
you know I mean sure you can give up
your Bishop on e4 but I really like my
Bishop I don't want to give it up I mean
in this case it's acceptable but
not quite what I did so after Bishop E4
yes he played 95 which is a very bad
move and I was really hoping he would
play this it's also the most natural
move because like if you think about it
almost every single opening we have seen
in our like life just very fast forward
like Fast back I would say let's say you
play the French right you play the
French
I don't know you go Knight F Knight D7
your idea is always to go like Knight F6
stuff like that you always want to put
your uh Knight to F6 and then recapture
with this Knight it's just a common
response Knight on D7 goes to F6 in like
so many different openings so my
opponent played that why is this a
mistake well
um
the mistake is exactly mentioned in the
chat Knight E5
and this is the trick but I was really
hoping my opponent Falls for why is this
a trick well if you take I give a check
and if you take now you lose your queen
so you just lost your queen for two
pieces but then
you're not gonna get out of this
so what my opponent did is he took my
Bishop I mean of course I wanted to have
my Bishop yes that's correct but in this
case he is just not developing anymore
there is no there is no development what
is the threat of Knight E5 the threat of
Knight E5 is just preventing my opponent
from developing that's it we're playing
in a battlefield where I have all my
attackers and you don't have any
attacker you're you're just sitting down
you can't play Bishop D7
that's it so I asked myself what is my
opponent's idea with Knight F6 it's not
to take my Bishop the idea is to get the
bishop out to somewhere there
so now
95. and takes takes yeah he can play
Rook B8 yes that's true you can do that
and the game would still go on but for
example it might be too slow I'll go G4
maybe and then try to go G5 and yes
you're probably gonna run your pawns
also down the board or maybe B5 maybe a
bit more
with some more Venom but I just go
trying to mate the king yes you can play
Bishop B7 yes you can be annoying you're
not you're never gonna take this guy
right it's impossible I'm just gonna
Retreat and then continue my attack
maybe push right find your line here
takes
takes check there mate I just made this
up but it's funny so that's the point
B5 does look strong but it's just not
it's not doing anything there is no
threat like even if I'm scared I'll just
go C4 you cannot break through I'm gonna
put this Pawn on B3 you're never gonna
go through anywhere like this Pawn chain
you're not gonna be in time while you're
getting checkmated you can do anything
you want on the queen side I can also
Fork you with Knight D7 at sometimes
although in this case G5 is angry so I'm
gonna be more focused on your king
before my king is even in danger it's
about who made two first it's not really
about
um anything else
so
and then he played this move Queen E7
which is also a very bad move
um his point basically is
that he wants to go F6 I guess
and then
E5 that's what he wants and the reason
he did not play F6 here
um
as far as I remember
it might be Queen G6
if I remember correctly
it might be Queen G6
I'm threatening this guy and after Rook
f8
I do have some stuff here that I'm for
sure of
let's let's see what it is
um
don't quite remember what it is trying
to calculate as we were talking of
course
what is it with check it rotates six
possible Rook 86 Queen E5 that's what
I'm calculating
instead of Queen G6 Rook H6 yes Queen
takes
and then
Knight D7 yeah yeah that's another line
I don't see the win in this one though
although check
it's close actually maybe it's winning
check here
check King goes there so we couldn't
meet him yet
okay
let's let's let's verify our opinion if
F6
Queen G6 yeah correct Rooker f8 F4
okay
I feel like I did see something like
this in the game and after it takes now
Rook 86 yep that makes sense
and then this is coming
okay that helps
so my opponent played Queen E7 I was
shocked when he played Queen E7 to be
honest and here I played F4 so same idea
as we just saw I did play this move F4
and my opponent here played Rook d8 he
could have he could have maybe played um
F6
but then
F6 definitely loses
this I know
let's see if you guys can find it
and I'll just verify my opinion yep that
was it
that was it yep
now I remember how the lines go
F6 this is his point and when I played
F4 I knew that I'm preventing F6
with a very
sneaky idea the idea is this and after
takes Rook H6 we just saw something like
that and the point the actual point is
after Queen F7 I have Rook h a check
takes Queen takes next move Rook H1
checkmate
so my opponent played the move Rook d8
his pieces are not moving I just took it
took it and then brought this Rook so
now I don't really want to Checkmate
them anymore because I don't have to
Checkmate him his pieces are not
developed they're not going to develop
if I don't want them to develop
I am keeping them all hostage here with
all my pieces with my Rook with my
knight
I'm just saying you're replying down a
rook and Bishop so he played this move
Queen C7
and here I played a super annoying move
I would say I did
um
I did quite annoy him with this move I
would say
I played the move Queen C4 I'm like I
want to trade Queens
and if you take my queen my point was to
go Rook d8 check in between move and
after King H7 I take
and my next move is going to be Knight
D6 and in this situation if you want to
get out of
this pin what you would want to do is go
B6 and then Bishop B7 so you so that you
can defend but then I still go on Knight
D6
I hit the bishop and after Bishop B7 so
close but yet so far I take the bishop
and defend my Rook so this was the whole
idea of playing Queen to C4
super annoying but it works my opponent
is like no
I don't want you to
trade Queens
and then here I played them of Queen to
A3 with the eye Queen to A4 sorry I
wanna go Queen EA check
and then pick up F7
my opponent played King f8 he's like
nope I don't want you to go there
and now
check
my opponent I was expecting him to go to
G8 but then I would have played this
move Queen to E7 and then just pick up
everything and it's gonna be made very
soon
so my opponent played the move King E8
all right now how do we proceed in this
position
and I'll answer some questions do you
study your opponent's games
yeah you have to do all of that you have
to study for your opponent's games you
have to study your own openings you have
to work on tact tactics excuse me you
have to do many things
many many things
which openings are most of the GM
studying is well that's exactly what I'm
showing the London the London is exactly
good for lazy people like me
you know
if you're a college student at the same
time and you're also a GM at the same
time you don't have much time to always
work on just so you just play something
that's relatively easy to play this is
exactly the topic of today
um
so yeah Knight C4 yes
Knight C4 was played
my opponent played Queen A6 he's like
give me the queen what do we do
now what he wants to trade Queens like I
just wanted a few moves ago
um
what do we do
how do we end the game it's very close
by the way the end is quite close and I
would say nice
although
yeah
how much serious work would get to the
Master title for a 1700 Blitz
wow that is completely up to you I would
say you should work quite a bit
to get to master Knight D6 yes
here my opponent can't step on the D
file
right
because I will just
if he steps on the D file I'll take this
with check worst case worst case there's
probably better but worst case I'm gonna
take his Rook I mean not bad right
so my opponent played King f8 all right
now how do we finish the game this is
the last part of the game
were ending
so it's white to play
Knight F5
Knight F5 people says Knight C8 also
good
night C8 Knight F5 yeah everyone is in
shape so what happens after Knight C8
Queen takes A3
what do you do
Checkmate right
but I was like I'm gonna do this fancier
I don't want it to be like this like
this bishop didn't move the whole game
it would be disrespectful to take it
right
so I'm like I'm not going to take your
Bishop I played Knight F5
and my opponent unfortunately I
highlight this word unfortunately he
took my queen and then it's made
I did deliver the Checkmate but the
reason I said it's unfortunate because I
really hoped my opponent played the move
King G8
and what was my idea after King G8 I
really wanted this queen of it yeah
this is what I was really hoping for and
this would have been a beautiful way to
end the game and after King takes then
Rook d8
that would have actually been a nice end
to this game
um yeah so hopefully this was this was
fun
as as I always show
a lot of tactics
a lot of
sacrifices
you know all sorts of tactics in my
games and whenever I played the London I
really like to play it in the more
Dynamic style
um
although
it sometimes is a boring opening but I
would say if you can make it interesting
if you can play it very sharp it's
definitely an opening you can play
dynamically and play it for a decent
Advantage so
yeah thank you all for watching
hopefully you enjoyed and learned
something and hopefully you'll be
playing uh the London yourself and
getting wins like this so thank you all
and take care
[Music]